this guy had a question about getting  complacent in life listen closely to my  answer so we're from eastern europe me  and my friend yeah we're from bulgaria  ourselves and  it's kind of like a summer camp for us  and then we fly back to europe and the  thing what happens is we are somewhat  obsessed with what we do and then we get  fly back home with like 100k hours and  then eternity in bulgarian labs and we  live like kings we don't have to do it  because of like  standards  i start feeling my complacency  i wanted to ask you since you've had  like many achievements in your life  where you're like i don't want to live  like a kid  [Music]  yeah that makes sense that's the answer  to the question  it gives me  complacency absolutely  [Music]